hi i'm james and i'll be presenting this
work indistinguishability obfuscation of
null quantum circuits and applications
uh which is joint work with giulio
malavolta
so first i'll
share some background on the notion of
indistinguishability obfuscation or i o
for classical circuits
so an obfuscator is a compiler that
takes as input it's a description of a
computer program so for now think of it
as a classical program and outputs an
obfuscated program and so the point of
obfuscation is to scramble a program to
hide its implementation details while
maintaining the functionality of the
program
okay and so the security of i o
says that
for any two programs p1 and p2 that
compute the same functionality their
obfuscations should be computationally
indistinguishable
okay
and this notion has been extremely well
studied over the past decade now um in
the world of classical cryptography and
it's even been dubbed a central hub of
cryptography because of all of its
applications
and so we can quickly uh see just the
sheer number of applications that
you know obfuscation or io has in the
classical setting
um
including fully homomorphic encryption
witness encryption multi-party and
unattractive key exchange and the list
goes on and on
um and also over the past you know 10
years there's been a huge amount of work
on
constructions of classical obfuscation
starting with some initial candidate
constructions that showed basically the
plausibility of eye over general
circuits um there's been a whole line of
research
constructing io
by going through the functional
encryption route
and
today the state of the art is that well
we know how to construct obfuscation for
all classical circuits from well-founded
assumptions
including assumptions on bi-linear maps
which are not post quantum so there's
also another line of work that has also
been focusing recently on building on
post-quantum malfunction and we have
some good
heuristic
candidates for that
okay
so
this talk is going to be about the
notion of quantum obfuscation which is a
a natural extension to
um considering quantum programs right so
now let's say q is some quantum program
it could be a unitary or more generally
a quantum circuit we'd like to well
we're wondering if we can obfuscate it
okay and there's been much less work on
the notion of quantum obfuscation okay
um a few works uh recently have studied
just some definitions and some
impossibilities so putting forth
different definitions of quantum
obfuscation showing that some of them
are impossible
okay
but if we look at like a similar chart
of like applications and constructions
it's much less uh
um you know well studied in the
classical setting in terms of
applications
um quantum and distinguishability
obfuscation is known to imply
this primitive called witness encryption
for qma and i will actually define this
later in the talk
and in terms of constructions a few
works have have studied this so a couple
works have have looked at um
how to obfuscate like basically
perfectly obfuscate certain very limited
classes of quantum functionalities
and so perfect obfuscation means that
actually the obfuscated programs are
perfectly indistinguishable from each
other
but we can hope to do a perfect
obfuscation for
you know all polynomial time quantum
circuits so we'll need to move to
computational assumptions and there has
been a
work that addresses this and shows how
to
obtain quantum i o for circuits with
clifford gates plus a few like
logarithmically many uh t gates so this
is some class of circuits quantum
circuits that we do know how to
obfuscate i'm assuming classical i o
okay but this is pretty much um
all of
um the prior work on quantum obfuscation
okay
and
in fact it's still open
um whether it's even possible to realize
in this notion of indistinguishability
obfuscation for all
efficient quantum circuits for general
quantum circuits so this is a question
that was kind of
you know addressed in the classical
setting around a decade ago in those
first works that showed candidate
constructions for classical obfuscation
this is still completely open in the
quantum setting in particular we don't
even have any candidates to
constructions
we don't even know if we can obfuscate
quantum circuits
i'm using ideal classical obfuscation
for example
okay
um so this is some background on
classical
io and quantum io
um so
our work is
um
basically our results are split up into
two parts um we have some results on the
construction side and some results on
the application side of quantum
obfuscation okay
so first i'll describe
the construction
or our results here so assuming the
quantum hardness of learning with errors
which is a pretty standard post quantum
hardness assumption
along with a virtual black box
obfuscated for classical circuits
we can show that there exists an office
skater
um oh that you know can be applied to
quantum functionalities or
general quantum circuits but the
following properties
so for correctness
we show that the obfuscation
roughly preserves the functionality of q
so it's exactly the functionality of q
up to some negligible factors
and then for security
we can show that for any pair of quantum
circuits q1 and q2 such that both q1 and
q2 output 0 with overwhelming
probability on every input meaning these
are both
so-called null quantum circuits that
their obfuscations are computationally
indistinguishable and so this is exactly
the quantum analog of a previously
studied notion of like of null and
distinguishability obfuscation in the
classical setting
okay
and
um before moving on i wanted to say like
highlight this assumption a little bit
more
so in fact
you know it's actually been known um for
20 years at least in the classical
setting and there's been some recent
works on this in the quantum setting
that it's impossible to in in general
construct a
uh virtual black
black box office skater um that
satisfies you know that satisfies vbb
security for all um classical circuits
but
um our construction that uses vbb
obfuscation can be heuristically
instantiated with um
indistinguishably obfuscated for
classical circuits um that's post
quantum
and
you know one could assume that the
resulting um
construction is secure
okay um because for one these
impossibility results only um you know
uh
only hold for like very specific um
contrived um circuits
um and this is similar to something you
might do in the random oracle model
since we know we can't you know actually
instantiate the random oracle model in
the real world what we do is we you know
replace the random article with a
concrete hash function and assume
security still holds okay
so
um the other thing i wanted to say about
this assumption is that uh in the paper
we actually show also how to replace a
vbb obfuscation with classical i o along
with this new notion of what we call
dual mode classical verification of
quantum computation
um unfortunately also
this is also a you know this notion is
something we also only have heuristic
candidates for so basically the bottom
line is that what we give is a candidate
or heuristic construction of of
indistinguishability obfuscation for a
large class of quantum circuits namely
all mill circuits
okay
so this is our main construction uh the
second part of our results is on the
application side so like i just
mentioned this is
what we construct quantum metal io and
in fact our
obfuscated circuit actually has a
classical description okay and so we
show that this implies witness
encryption for qma also with a classical
ciphertext okay
and then we show that windows encryption
for qma is actually a very useful notion
it has all of these applications okay
including a um non-attractive zero
knowledge proof for qma
um and so we give
basically the first candidate
construction of this primitive and is
increama
we showed
how to construct the related notion of
two message witness and
distinguishability for qma
we show how to construct a
attribute-based encryption scheme for a
quantum complexity class bqp
and attribute-based encryption is this
fine-grained notion of public encryption
that is very well studied in the
classical setting and we give the first
you know candidate construction of it
for a quantum complexity class and we
also have results on constrained prfs
for bqp and secret sharing for monotone
qma
and i should say actually a lot of these
applications or implications also um
requires to classical and
distinguishability obviously
okay
um but yeah i
will encourage you to i'll refer to the
paper for actually all of these um
descriptions of all these primitives and
all these implications
um for the rest of this talk i just
wanted to talk about uh first this
implication so quantum nullio implies
witness encryption for qma
and then um give an overview of how we
actually construct the quantum nullio
okay
so first witness encryption for qma so
what is it
so let l be a language in qma
um a witness encryption scheme uh the
encryption algorithm takes as input a
message m and an instance x
okay and produces a ciphertext such that
if x is an l then any witness psi for x
so this is a you know quantum complexity
class qma any witness psi for x can be
used to decrypt the ciphertext and learn
the message m
on the other hand if x is not in the
language then
basically the cipher text completely
hides m in the sense that no efficient
adversary can recover m from the central
text okay
so
how do we construct such a scheme from
quantum null i o
well
if we want to encrypt the message m
under an instance x
we'll first define the circuit q mx to
be the circuit that takes his input psi
and then outputs m if and only if psi is
a witness for x so what the circuit does
is it just runs the qma verification
circuit over x and psi if it
accepts it outputs m if it rejects it
i'll put say some some bot symbol
okay and then the
cipher text is actually just going to be
a null obfuscation
of the circuit
okay
and so why
does this work well so for correctness
the correctness of our null io directly
implies the correctness of this witness
encryption scheme um because you know
given a witness
uh you can run this officiate obfuscated
circuit which will behave just like q
and output m
if psi is actually witnessed for x
and then security
of the null i o um suffices to prove
security of this witness encryption
scheme right because if x is not an l
then q is actually a null circuit okay
so the security of an obfuscator
actually um implies that m basically
remains hidden
in the set for text okay
so this is uh the implication and this
is just directly follows a um
the classical um it's been known that
like basically um classical knowledge
implies witness encryption for np so
this is kind of the quantum analog of
that
implication
okay
so now i want to say about um some words
about how we actually build a quantum
null io scheme so
it's not too complicated we basically
make use of just two tools okay
so the first is a two message blind
classical verification of quantum
computation protocol or cbqc
so
what is this protocol it's a protocol
between a classical verifier who has
um
some quantum circuit queue that would
like to run but it can't because it's
classical so it's going to interact with
the quantum prover
okay
and so the verifier will first run some
gen algorithm to produce some public
parameters the preview will run some
proof algorithm to output some proof pi
and the verifier we'll run some again
some classical output algorithm on q and
and pi to produce its output y
okay
and so we want to um ensure some
properties out of such a scheme so one
is blindness but the prover actually
can't learn anything about q from these
public parameters okay so the prover
doesn't actually learn what circuit the
verifier is interested in um and running
now there is soundness um which means
that you know if we want to evaluate q
um on x or
then
um samus says that the prover can't
force the verifier to output a wrong
output okay so the verifier will always
you know accept the negative probability
output um
of the correct output y equals q of x
okay
um and we can obtain such a scheme by
combining so in prior works it was
already known how to construct at least
a hero stick construction in the random
oracle model of a two-message cbqc which
um
you know cbqc was first constructed in
this work of mahadev and then these
follow-up works showed how to
compress the round complexity
um
and then we can basically just run such
a scheme under quantum fully homomorphic
encryption okay uh to make it blind
so this is the first tool uh the second
tool is just an obfuscator for classical
circuits okay
so given these two tools
our construction is quite simple
so if we want to obfuscate the circuit
queue
what we'll do is we'll just first run
the verifier generation algorithm on
queue to produce these public parameters
and then
we'll output a classical obfuscated
version of the verif of the verifier's
output functionality okay so
this is actually the entire construction
of quantum nullio it's just these public
parameters and
you know a classical obfuscation of this
verifier's output functionality
um to evaluate this so
say you're you you know you have some
input x or actually in general even x
could be a quantum input as well and you
want to evaluate this um
on
um you want to evaluate this obfuscation
you would just run the prover algorithm
the cvqc scheme to produce your proof pi
input into the classical obfuscation um
to learn y
which should be equal to q of x
so
yeah this is how the scheme works
and now i just want to say a little bit
about how intuitively why this is secure
okay so
let's consider any null circuit cue
what we can say is that this classical
obfuscation or this classical oracle v
out of q
um can be replaced with all zeros oracle
so an oracle that just responds
does output zero on every input okay and
so why is that well
any adversary that can distinguish these
two oracles we can use to actually break
the soundness of the cvqc right because
um
you know any input that actually causes
this oracle to output one um
isn't you know is a proof that can be
used to break the soundness of cbqc
okay
right so here we rely on soundness and
then finally after we do this after we
replace this with the all zeros oracle
we can just note that these public
parameters hide q due to the blindness
of the cvqc scheme
and so basically what we've shown is the
two components of this null i o we've
shown are you know essentially like
computationally
independent of the
underlying circuit queue
okay
so this is roughly why our
scheme is secure
okay
so
yeah before i ended i just wanted wanted
to
talk about
a couple possible extensions or open
problems
suggested by this work
so
you know first
you could ask okay well i just described
why security holds for null circuits but
why are we stopping there um why can't
we use this um
you know
this paradigm to obfuscate um
you know maybe all quantum circuits or
at least
more quantum circuits than just null
ones okay
so the issue is that if you think about
the um
you know the evaluator or the adversary
in the quantum obfuscation game
they have access to the obfuscated
verification circuit which they can run
multiple times right
and so
[Music]
you know in order to argue that this is
secure that they're not like learning
anything about the underlying circuit
you'd have to you'd have to use the fact
that the underlying cvqc is actually
reusably sound blind meaning that a
cheating prover can
basically query the verifier multiple
times and still blindness and soundness
holds so
um unfortunately we actually at least
for like non-null circuits right we
actually show explicit attacks on the
reusability of cvtc protocols okay so
this leads to a nice open question of
whether we can actually construct cvqc
protocols that are reusably sound and
blind okay
um the next you could ask well why do we
need to rely on classical virtual black
box obfuscation could we rely on the
weaker notion of indistinguishability
obfuscation
so here the issue is that the soundness
of tvqc is not perfect in fact
um there will exist many
even exponentially many like bad
accepting proofs
um even for like a null circuit right
and the point is that a uh
cheating prover just shouldn't be able
to find one of these bad accepting
proofs
but we need to use the uv obfuscation in
order to extract such a bad proof from a
cheating adversary to get the reduction
to cvqc to go through and it's not clear
how to do this um if we only relied on
indistinguishability
okay so this like you know these lead to
these two um open question
questions first um you know can we
obtain a candidate construction or
here's the construction of i o for all
quantum circuits okay so this remains
open
and next can we obtain any of our
results you know so complemental i o
witness encryption for qma nizik for qma
um from just i o for classical circuits
plus maybe some other standard hardness
assumptions
okay
and so
that's all i wanted to say so thank you
for listening